but how how do we take this idea of one
planet thriving and
put it into practice well for that i
believe we need new economic models
we need to shift into a post-growth
mindset get off our addiction to endless
growth and i think
one of the most important models that we
could start thinking about is what's
known as the donut the donut of social
and planetary boundaries
developed by the british economist kate
rayworth
and the way the donut works is this
there's two rings
there is a social foundation things like
water food basic health care
and the aim we should be prioritizing is
bringing people above that basic
social foundation but we need to do it
without pushing out
ourselves beyond the ecological ceiling
that's the outer ring of the donut
and the ecological ceiling is made up of
the nine planetary boundaries they're
called
which have been developed by earth
system scientists like johann rockstrom
and will stefan
things like climate change and ocean
acidification
caring for our soils chemical pollution
so
this model is not about growing growing
growing it's about
thriving in balance it's about getting
into the safe and just space for
humanity
that sweet spot that light green area
there
this is what i believe the goal for
governments today should be
to ensure our long-term future but can
we actually live within the doughnut
well let's have a look
at where we are today on a global level
this is our selfie and what a
devastating one it is
there's a shortfall on all of the social
foundations on a global level people
not able to meet their basic food or
health and other requirements that's
what those little red segments are
and when it comes to the ecological
sealing we're going over
at least four planetary boundaries the
ones for which we have good data
already and this doughnut model has also
been scaled down from the global level
to the national level
it's being used in cities such as
amsterdam it's being used
by progressive companies so i believe
that this is the kind of economic
thinking
we absolutely need for a long-term
future